let's go to andrew from brooklyn andrew
welcome
hi david
can you hear me yes i can
hey so i was talking with some friends
the other day we're talking about the j6
uh hearings and so forth and they're not
right-wing they're not left-wing they're
progressive so on and so forth and they
felt like actually maybe wait hold on a
second
let me just see if you're saying the
people you were talking to aren't
right-wing or left-wing they are
progressive isn't progressive the same
as left-wing
yes correct so centrists i guess they
would call themselves i'm not really
sure what they call it wait they are or
they are not progressives
i i don't remember but they don't
consider themselves either democrat or
republican okay all right go on uh
they're an interracial
they're an interracial couple
um
my friend nicole's had had had an
abortion
and but as far as j6 is concerned they
were saying you know maybe we should you
know overthrow our government or at
least overhaul it i mean it has so many
and not in the way it was done on j6
obviously but what's your feeling i mean
do we need like a complete overhaul of
the government the u.s government uh
no i don't
think so i mean it depends on what you
have in mind i think there's a lot of
problems that i would try to solve like
for example i think we should have a
national popular vote vote rather than
an electoral college i just don't think
an overthrow is going to achieve that
because
of the framework that exists legally in
in the country uh i i'm not sure i mean
i think
i
almost anyone would agree that there are
things that need to be fixed and
repaired
but that an overthrow of the government
is unlikely to achieve that
right well i actually meant overhaul not
overthrow yeah sure there's lots of
things that need to be overhauled we
need to overhaul how health insurance is
organized in the country we need to
overhaul how we do elections overhaul
campaign finance there's tons of stuff
that needs to be police reform and on
and on
but uh i i'm with you there we
definitely need an overhaul
yeah and i mean i i had a terminal brain
cancer two brain surgeries which i've
talked about on your channel in the chat
and so forth and i mean my 500 000 you
know medical bill uninsured the medical
system for sure needs an overhaul again
i'm saying overhaul not overthrown i'm
with you absolutely absolutely you need
an overhaul right
so i'm i'm i i just want you know i
really appreciate your show and that
jack broke the rules and asked you how
you're doing so i know i know that was
horrible that was horrible andrew thank
you for the call
all right brother all right take care
there's andrew from brooklyn wishing you
the best